if you are headed out to life is
beautiful this weekend you're surely
going to hear about tequila corrido they
are the official tequila partner of the
festival and joining us to show us a
little more about some of the exquisite
cocktails you can have with them is
mixologist thomas bruce welcome thank
you for having me this is very exciting
the official tequila of life is
beautiful absolutely and you guys are
going to be all over the place first of
all what does tequila korido mean
so in the hispanic culture there are
poetic love songs called as balor so
that is essentially where the credo
comes from oh
hispanic love songs i love that and you
guys have three different varieties of
tequila corridor tell us a little bit
about them yes so tequila currito is
going to be a small batch product where
all the blue weber agave is found in
mexico so you have the blanco here which
has a slight pepper component to it the
represatto did amazing in the san
francisco uh winning two gold awards and
then you have the enejo which is aged in
merlot barrels okay so we're going to
make a cocktail which tequila are we
going to use so we're going to be using
the blanco tequila here the pepper
components are going to go awesome with
the habanero water and the prickly pear
to smooth it out okay so you can get
this at life is beautiful this weekend
yes absolutely and if you can't make it
to life is beautiful you can get it at
about 50 different locations throughout
the city including lee's liquor store
okay so let's uh let's make this
cocktail here prickly pear margarita you
said we're going to go with the most
important ingredient here about two
ounces of carrito blanco all right and
you're not getting cheap on us here with
them not at all you're going to do one
ounce of fresh lime juice here
this will be nice and refreshing if it's
warm out there no absolutely and this is
going to be a house made prickly pear
syrup with just a wild forged prickly
pear a little sweetness and then
habanero water to add a little bit of
spice i'm curious about this habanero
water this sounds interesting okay you
mix it all together
i'm excited and you're going to have
other cocktails out there maybe yes
absolutely so we're going to have our
version of a paloma with beaver tree
orange and then a classic margarita with
a little bit of fresh lime topped off
with some soda water and then this is
going to be kind of the star of the show
in our minds i am excited i will be out
there and so you can expect to see me
at some of these places getting these
okay oh look at this let's take a little
uh sip
the tequila corridor
quickly pear margarita and i what's on
the side here so that's going to be a
smoke tahin rim oh all right so we're
stepping it up a few different ways
there
oh my gosh it's so smooth oh delicious
absolutely it's a very uh the tequila
does all the work there for you i'm
going to call an uber so i can finish
this so he can go home tonight i don't
know this is fantastic thank you so much
and where can people get tequila
corridor so like i said at the local lee
liquor store and there's about 50 other
locations throughout restaurants bars
casinos so just start looking for
tequila credo it is a certified additive
free tequila and it's a wonderful
product it is delicious thank you so
much thomas check them out at life is
beautiful i'm going to send it back to
you kendall all right